hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar what is needed for optimal
experimental design and how this might
be taught to laboratory animal
scientists am Judy Oracle's lab roots
and I'll be moderating this session
today's educational webinar is presented
by lab routes leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific elaborate star tit this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
race continuing education credits after
the webinar is over and to get your te
credits click on the CD button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them into the Q&A box which
will open when you click the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker Derek fry
faculty of life sciences university of
manchester dr. fry is a medical doctor
and also a Doctor of Philosophy who has
been interested in experimental design
since including statistics in his
medical student teaching in the 1980s he
continued that interest when he moved to
UK government work which involves
assessing proposals for animal
experiments in many different fields and
advising on biomedical issues in
animal-based research and testing hiring
he was granted an honorary position at
the University of Manchester and has
been running for helping run workshops
on experimental design in the UK and
various countries New York Asia and
North America and exploring how to teach
the subject in an interesting and
entertaining way dr. Frey will now begin
his presentation thank you Judy
first of all I should save it in this
rather strained arrangement you can't
make these presentations as interesting
and exciting as one can when you have an
audience to react with immediately but I
should try and give you some questions
as we go through I was concerned really
about how you taught this particular
subject experimental design because I
came across a lot of bad teaching now
the subject here is really not just
experimental design in the broad scope
but also optimizing experimental design
and I think if you're going to think
about teaching that you've got to first
think about what it is you want those
who are being taught to actually pick up
and take away with them from a
presentation or a learning experience
and so therefore we're going to go
through a lot of this in terms of
working out what would be best to put in
a course or a presentation or a series
of lectures on experimental design which
show how you can optimize that and then
we will think a little bit about how the
teaching could be presented and what
sort of results you might expect from
that with different audiences so to
start with let's have a look first of
all about what might be optimal
experimental design and I do apologize
four bullet points of several points
here I have tried several different
types of bullet points which have all
come out as a tea not on my sides but
when it gets translated into the lab
root system so just what rities think of
them as diamonds or squares anyway
experimental design optimizing I think
it would keep traffic or principles and
it should provide results which are
valid reliable reproducible and as
widely applicable as possible
and that's quite a challenge but also it
needs to be efficient in use of animals
and resources and to minimize the impact
of the experiments on the animals that
is the severity distress they experience
so let's have a look at the ethical
considerations the first one is to think
is it actually worth doing the
experiments at all does the sort of cost
or severity that the animals experience
is that worth the sort of data you will
be getting out and that's called a
cost-benefit analysis and it's one of
the things that is worth putting in at
an early stage when you're teaching
experimental design the next thing is to
look at the classic 3 R's arrangement
they that is replacing by using non
animal alternatives reducing the number
of animals over both the experiments and
a series of experiments and using the
minimal severity procedures or causing
the least harm or distress and you may
regard poorly designed experiments as
unethical because they either use too
many animals or not enough to show good
results or they use too much in the way
of distress and harm to the animal for
the results you're getting out if they
use too many animals you're wasting
animals forward end results that you're
looking for and if they use to few
animals on each experiment you're
wasting animals by failing to show real
effect and needing to have other
experiments to show that effect so very
quickly we replace
ethical consideration starts with a
question is it necessary to use animals
and before saying yes you should really
think about computer modeling in vitro
possibilities ex vivo possibilities like
using tissue and do a systematic review
to make sure that the experiment
proposed along with sort of lines you're
proposing is actually necessary I you
could ask if I could not use live
animals what could I do or there's not a
way of doing it and that is to say could
I alter the objective so it was
achievable with tissue culture or ex
vivo material without using live animals
during the experiment the most of the
experimental design thought pattern is
about reduction or cutting down on
animal use and that can be achieved both
by the design of an individual
experiment but also by the design of a
program experiments a series of
experiments to a common name you can
reduce by minimizing variability and
that's where consideration of good
health status comes in minimizing
distress and you can also reduce by
collaborating across groups and making
certain other publications include all
the elements that are necessary to
repeat or judge the experiments that
you're publishing you can maximize the
use of tissue across different groups in
particular make available genetically
altered lines there is an element to
which you would keep the numbers down by
using the same animal more than once are
you re using an animal but clearly that
adds to the cumulative stress of the
animal if you're not careful when you
give groups a discussion about why they
would design an experiment
and the sort of results you get out of
here obtaining valid results knowing how
widely those results may apply is it
just to the particular circumstance of
that experiment or is it much wider to
use resources people's time the animals
and the equipment efficiently and to
minimize the impact on the animals or
the severity for procedures but also to
ensure reproducibility so those need to
be in your mind when you're thinking
about optimizing and experiment the
design and therefore they need to be
part of any teaching approach and be
emphasized and you can save a good
experiment design calls for combination
a biological insight which you need to
formulate a good experimental question
and logic to work out a testable
hypothesis around that particular
question but also an element of common
sense to realize what you can do in the
time or with the other constraints and
to plan accordingly and right at the end
of this comes the appreciation of
statistics because of the back of your
mind you have to know how to results can
be properly analyzed but in the way the
statistics comes last and the biology
comes first so if you're thinking about
optimizing you will think about
formulating a clear objective designing
for minimal severity designing for the
results to be valid and the experiments
reproducible getting sequences of
experiments that give minimum numbers
and minimal severity overall and getting
the right numbers for each experiment in
the program to achieve that
and the steps you might think of in
designing an experiment were specifying
the objective formulating the hypothesis
from that deciding the best measures
considering how you would get the best
effect a biggest effect on the least
variability identifying the experimental
unit and then planning the design or
arrangement of experimental units around
controls and experimental alterations
within the constraints of the type of
housing that the biological material is
in animals fish and that sort of thing
but you have to know how to arrange the
allocation of units to get an efficient
design and in order to get an efficient
design you need to know how you will
analyze those results um into that you
will put certain ideas about what
significance level or risk of
false-positive you will accept and what
power or ability to recognize a real
effect you are happy with and from those
elements you will estimate the group
size for a particular comparison of a
problem about objectives is one that is
sufficient to make it a key element of
any teaching about optimizing
experimental design because unclear
objectives are one of the most common
failures and only yesterday I was giving
a group a task to devise an experiment
and the first thing they come up with
was an objective which had two or three
possibilities in it you have to be clear
about what you want and what is your
priority in also be able to formulate
the experimental design properly because
good objectives
give clear hypotheses and clear
hypotheses lead to the best experiments
have a look at this objective our
objective is to determine how strokes
can be prevented very broad and laudable
but actually very difficult to know
whether you could achieve it or we're in
the particular timeframe and how you
would achieve it what hypothesis are you
putting forward if you rephrase it as
our objective is to test the reduction
in stroke occurrence when a standard
diet is supplemented with antioxidants
then you have a framework of a testable
hypothesis as biological experiments
comparative you don't get a clear end
result without a decent comparison and
do that you need to keep certain
fundamental principles because if you
don't the results have a certain degree
of uncertainty and you don't know how
much and there is a bias that may be
possible and again you would not be
aware of it and if those are there you
get unreliable results you may get
erroneous conclusions and it may take a
lot of other experiments to correct that
particularly if it gets into literature
or a journal with high impact factor so
the fundamental principles are something
that you would definitely put in any
teaching program and think a worth
emphasizing and I would think the ones
that are particularly key are getting
appropriate comparisons you she would
have controls and usually they would be
concurrent but you have to set them up
so they are appropriate and relevant and
there are cases when you can use
historic controls as long as you have
some concurrent ones you also need to
have
all bits the biological material in each
of the experimental conditions because
if there's only one you don't know
whether it's the biological material
itself it's causing changes between two
conditions or whether it's the
conditions and so you need a number of
these so-called replicates in order to
be able to detect a genuine difference
between different experimental groups
but those replicates must be capable of
being assigned independently to
different experimental groups and in
doing the assignment you have to
randomize because unless you randomize
you have the possibility of bias and you
wouldn't know but it is not just
randomization when you assign two
treatments or you select from a group it
is randomization throughout the
experiment where there might be a bias
that you are not aware of and these
fundamental principles all relate to a
think all the experimental unit which is
shown in some of the textbooks on
experimental design but not all and it
can be defined as the repetition unit or
that element of biological material that
can be independently assigned at random
to any of the experimental treatments we
look at experimental units a little bit
later on but first of all let's consider
controls because they are a fundamental
way of checking that you don't get force
inferences classically you may consider
them as negative or positive internal or
external and concurrent or historic
internal by the way is where the animal
or experiment
unit is its own control for in a
particular manipulation for example you
take a baseline put in a vehicle and
look at how that affects the baseline
you then put in your drug of interest
compare that effect and then you put in
the vehicle again to make sure the
baseline and the effect on base time has
not changed external ones are the
typical ones where you do comparisons of
groups of biological material when
you're doing a straight comparison
however you don't need separate vehicle
or sham-operated controls one
experimental treatment can be the
control for the other and vice versa
provided that is the objective just
comparing the two and that can apply to
different procedures different strains
of animals different drugs and so on
essentially the interpretation of your
results is based on the relationship
between the treated responses whether
they be controls or comparison responses
and some of the problems of the controls
are effectively twofold one is that you
miss out necessary controls and the
other is you put in unnecessary ones so
again as this is such a critical area
it's important to put it in any approach
to teaching that involves optimizing
experimental design and to decide
suitable controls you need to think what
the outcomes of an experiment might be
then think how you might interpret those
outcomes and then think what controls
are needed to avoid misinterpreting and
particular there are occasions when you
have to say to yourself is a negative a
genuine negative or is it due to some
effect that is masking the effect of the
experimental manipulation and for those
sort of things you might need the
positive control to show that there is
an effect in the circumstances when you
think there ought to be randomization as
I've mentioned is about making sure that
you don't have a bias and in the
different groupings so it makes sure
that there is an equal chance of any
inherent difference being in any one of
your experimental treatment groups so it
avoids the possibility that the inherent
differences get plastered and associated
with particular treatments although to
be fair and that might be one possible
random outcome but the chances of that
are very low also you need to think
about randomizing at every stage of the
experiment because in allocating the
independent experimental units it's
relatively easy to see that they could
be biases which happened to go into one
group and give a force indication of the
response of that group to the
experimental changes but there's also
the problem but the observer or
manipulator all the person giving
injections gets better during the course
of an experimental series or it's more
tired and worse and also that where you
put the experimental units within the
particular experimental treatment groups
could be affected by the environment
equally you may get an effect of either
skill improvement or tiredness in a
series of measurements so you should
really be randomizing at each of those
stages and this is a fairly ancient set
of work looking at an animal house and
the effect of lighting on rodent caging
within it it's only really worth looking
at the grouping on the far right where
you have got a light source which is in
the ceiling and if you have an uncovered
top cage you have a much higher lighting
at the base of the cage then you do
right at the bottom of the rack where
there is shading from all the other
cages and where the amount of
illumination has reduced considerably so
that means that going down a rack with
illumination from the top you will get
different levels of lighting in the cage
and you can see some of the figures
there 250 for example in the top right
10 below it and then right at the bottom
figure drops two three that may not be a
problem but in species like rodents
which are more active at night than
during the day it may seriously
influential results because those in the
higher cages may be showing adverse
effects to the light and those in the
lower cages may be more active so you
have to take that into account and this
is why you would randomized where the
particular biological groups and
experimental groups are within the rack
now we talked about the experimental
unit and I gave you one definition here
is Syria
of others the unit of replication that
can be assigned at random to a treatment
the entity of bitter biological material
that can be signed independently to a
treatment group so there are two
elements here the random and the
independent and it's important to
recognize that the experimental unit may
not be an individual animal under quite
a number of circumstances groupings of
animals or parts of animals or a pattern
all animals may actually be the
experimental unit and in a crossover
design the experimental unit is the
biological material for a period of time
that is then compared against another
period of time and usually you're taking
your measurement on a sample from the
experimental unit so let's give you
something to think about a researcher
wishes to determine whether a drug
protects against the effect to the
mutation but a thanks late fetal
development and produces observable
effects after weaning he or she proposes
to randomly assign among homozygous
mutant females to drug treated and
control groups then mate them with the
appropriate males the drug will be given
during late pregnancy the litters weaned
appropriately grouped and the effects on
the offspring observed in that
arrangement what is the experimental
unit or would you think it was
individual offspring be the cage see the
female and D not sure now lab roots is
going to give you a chance to give a
response to that and after a little
while we'll close the poll and I'll give
you what I think is the response
I normally give about a minute for this
in an assessment which is not a serious
assessment that one that stimulates
thought and gives a chance to consider
the different options so ten seconds to
finish that and then if lab roots can
take it off will proceed to what I think
the answer is
okay can we now move on and see the
slide itself because I would say what
can be independently assigned to an
experimental group or treatment is the
female and of course you can't assume
that people are doing and the best
practice I was part of a survey then
kokanee at l 2009 we've got published
and looked at both sides of the Atlantic
and papers from a number of journals and
found that those papers which indicated
that they did random allocation animas
were really quite a small proportion and
those that actually blinded the person
are judging the result from the
treatment that the animal had received
for also a rather small proportion
things have got a bit better since and
it doesn't say they didn't but it
indicates they didn't think it was
important enough to put in the methods
sections and there's one particular
study which looked at and the abstracts
of studies which might have give
positive or negative results and this
was actually in a grouping form and
trauma scientists and generally you
would have thought there's a possibility
of getting positive or negative results
roughly fully but if the randomization
was not mentioned there was a greater
chance of the findings being reported as
positive than if it was and if either
randomization nor blinding were
ported again there was an even bigger
chance of positive findings being
published then published in the abstract
then am a negative ones so there is a
risk in this of allowing a bias to come
in which you don't see in the published
work and it's come out several times as
people have been looking across
different groupings and end results one
of the first ones was / elidel which are
looking at the correlation between an
outcome in animals and in outcoming
humans and the correlation was not good
this one by Scott atau was a very
extensive study looking at what is
published work of effects of different
treatments on this particular disease a
Mara topic natural sclerosis but when
they looked at all of them and assess
how they and gave their results and the
drift and patterns of them they felt
that most of them could be explained by
the natural variation the normal noise
pattern rather than any specific effects
of the agents it's very nicely
controlled and looked at study and is
worthwhile I'm studying in detail
similarly McLeod's group held up in
several publications from looking at the
and how genuinely can take published
work in particular areas such as the
stroke models where small amounts of
effect are clinically worthwhile but
there is a risk of bias which could
substantially change whether you thought
there was an effect or not and because
of this
back of randomization and blinding
several of these would be regarded as
suspect and more recently you had two
papers looking at repeating landmark
studies in house so these are across
several types of discipline they studies
have been published and what has
happened in different pharmaceutical
companies they have tried to reproduce
these in order to set up a drug
discovery program and found the degree
of ability to reproduce them is really
rather low and they've decided that the
probably poor design is a considerable
element of this that is not entirely
without questioning but it gives you a
good impression of the problems that
arise if it is not clear but there have
been a good design and that you can rely
on the outputs and the soul of problems
you find going around and talking to
scientists is that many don't know how
to randomize properly you don't just
pick the first animal becomes in the
cage because that may be the one that is
most anxious to bite you or the one that
can't run away faster and you've got a
risk also biased results because of the
way in which the studies were set out
and we've mentioned some of what is now
a considerable literature questioning
the quality of studies there is limited
information on planning of the sequence
experiments and including some ideas
about the three and ours is really quite
rare scientists the dinner access to
advise an experimental design it came
from statins and of course they will be
thinking about numbers efficient design
and that sort of thing and
not about what effect severity may have
on the data all the loss of data points
and if you look at the sort of failings
that you can see experimental objectives
and clear poor hypothesis you don't get
the constraints you forget that only a
period of time you can do things over
but you're going to take a period of
time to actually get an output and you
may not have the technical capacity to
get it within that time the idea of
getting the experimental unit corrected
not warmer comes into a lot of people's
fault patterns the controls may be
missing out on key positives you may not
have the best measures to get the
largest effect and you may not have
maximized that effect against the
variability quite often inefficient
designs are used to group or more group
comparisons when there could be a more
efficient way of doing it the sample
size is often miscalculated the units
and for measuring sometimes not
independent randomization may be done at
some stage but not throughout and
there's a lack of realization of a
possibility of observer bias there's
also quite a bit of incorrect analysis
again there's a number of published
studies which have looked at the
analysis and indicated that many of them
are incorrect for the type of data they
were getting and finally there is an
element of incorrect reporting and
presentation of course not every
experiment or experimental group has all
of these it's just these are relatively
common as you go around looking at
different experimental designs and of
course none of those include this
failure to actually go to the minimal
severity but this is an important
element because good science depends
upon good welfare physiological
responses to suffering they change
data quality consistency of validity and
of course we know anxiety pain fear and
distress can affect our physiology and
you would expect it to affect animal
physiology as well so you will get
changes in heart rate immune responses
and so on and one of the things that you
don't think about until it comes your
way is the extent to which minor welfare
problems can influence the reliability
reproducibility and consistency of your
results but another thing about
refinement which is not really to do
with the way in which you design is that
you do need to think about humane
endpoints some time when you will stop
the experiment or take the animal off
experiment because the severity is more
than you can justify from the results
you're getting out all because you have
reached your specified objective and any
further disturbance of the animal is not
really justifiable or it's become clear
you will not get to that objective and
you have to accept that any further
suffering is not going to give you
reliable data and of course taking annum
was off experiment mean may mean you've
lost a data point and you will need to
take account of that in the experimental
design and they have a problem about
considering it experimental design and
optimizing it as just reducing the
numbers if you don't think about
possible alter except the objectives you
don't think about this effect of pain or
distress and you don't think about the
variability that may cause in the
measure that you're taking and hence the
numbers that may be needed to
investigate a real effect but equally
the point about losing data is important
because you need to avoid designs that
would be highly sensitive to it there's
also the possibility of conflict between
reduction and refinement fewer animals
but more severity or do you go for lower
severity and larger number of animals
and the answer to the question depends
upon the particular thing you're doing
you might for example except the higher
severity of the implantation of the
cannula where we're using fewer animals
than you would need with a variability
of taking several samples of blood so
the key elements in good design you
might consider to be the objectives
maximizing the effect and minimizing
variation and getting an efficient
pattern of your experimental units and
experimental treatments and of course
we've mentioned the clear objective is
not uncommon we've done a number of
workshops in which people have looked at
the objectives in papers and taken the
first or main experiment and see to try
and see if they are clear as to what the
experimenters were trying to show and
typically we find a pottery half the
group's cannot find out what the
objective of that experiment was
probably more realistically is the
result that came from the companion tell
survey which is indicating that the
objectives were not clear in about five
percent of cases and of course you need
clear objectives because you can't
assess otherwise whether you need an
exploratory experiment on a hypothesis
testing one whether you need animals or
a suitable controls when it should be
stopped because it's been achieved or
cannot be achieved and how to design
properly
and one element we talked about in
improving and optimizing experiments is
to think closely about maximizing effect
and minimizing variation in the first
case you can increase the signal give a
larger stimulus use more sensitive
subjects in the second you can decrease
it by improving uniformity or
standardizing or doing a covariate
approach or you can improve the
experimental design so some elements of
variability can be excluded from the
comparison between the experimental
groups and their variability if you
can't do that you're stuck with
increasing the sample size so this is
one element that it would be key in
looking at how you teach them to
optimize experimental design and when
you look at the sources of noise or
variability those are the sort of things
you get 86 species strain health time
day training those are just the animal
factors there's also human factors and
environmental factors to consider and
you can think in another way of
classifying this what affects the
experiment is who does it or who is
associated with it what is the
arrangement and where is it taking place
and when are you taking the samples or
doing the experimental manipulations and
it's important to look at variability
carefully because if you look at a
standard measure for their ability the
standard deviation into the
circumstances I've given on the top
right for a team to sample comparison
and and these particular circumstances a
standard deviation as you can see from
the graph would mean a group size at
each of the two experimental groups
being compared at around eight
as you get a larger standard deviation
your group size goes up as you get a
smaller standard deviation of
variability the needed group size goes
down but if you look carefully at the
group size 4.6 on that graph you see
that there's around 20 animals per group
needed if you drop that 2.3 it's only
five so there is a squared effect
between the variability and the number
of animals you need to do it to sample
comparison and a similar effect is seen
in a more complex design whereby another
2 by 2 factorial experiment so the last
thing to think out and to make certain
is included in some form of approach to
t2 optimizing experimental design and
teaching about it is to match the design
to the experimental question as well as
getting the right group size and again
that's particular survey indicated that
where where you could use factorial
experiments in which you can gain more
information from the same number of
experimental units and only about half
or less and other papers actually took
to using a factorial design when there
was a possibility to do so and this is a
way of wasting animals for the amount of
information you can get out to classify
them you can think of a fully randomized
design of which one of the uses is a
two-sample comparison we've talked about
or you might have several sample
comparisons experimental group
comparisons another is a randomized
block factorial we've mentioned it tests
simultaneously different factors and
their effect
Pete measure is when you use the same
biological material over several periods
of time and sequential is when you do a
series of small experiments and the ones
further down the series are informed by
the earlier ones it's only possible if
data is obtainable reasonably quickly
and you have to be careful that there is
no time trend so that the later ones are
affected by some bias according to the
time in which they are done but provided
that's done you can get a very good
minimization of the use of animals to a
particular objective the important thing
though is to make quite certain that you
set stopping points beforehand so you
don't just carry on until you find out
what you want to find out anyway the
advantages and disadvantages are shown
briefly here the fully randomized design
and said two or several comparisons is
well understood but it may not be the
most efficient the randomized block
enables you to take out certain elements
of a variability from the comparison
between experimental groups and the
factorial gives you information on more
than one thing within the design and it
shows the interaction between those
elements but it can get very complex you
have to be careful in a repeat measures
design that there is no crossover
between the different time periods and
in a sequential design you've got to be
very careful you don't have a bias and
we've mentioned a number of terms factor
is simply a discrete characteristic or
source of their ability and typical
factors are the treatment the
experimental manipulations controls
drug-treated and so on the sex a strain
the litter of an animal may have come
from the diet which is given all the
in which an experiment was set up all of
those can be regarded as factors and
blocking is simply grouping according to
a characteristic or source of
variability and it's worthwhile in
certain circumstances we've mentioned
power and I've given an indication that
it is crucial to decide what are the
chances of getting a genuine result a
real result when it did it really exists
this is a typical randomized block
design for an animal studies you can
block our group are going to age or
parentage of acid thing this one is done
by time and you have four time periods
and you accept that you will not get all
of the experiment done in one of them
but you will be able to do the four
different surgical treatments during
that time period the important thing is
a to make certain that every one of the
treatments being compared is within the
block in this case of the time period
and that they are randomly arranged
within it and that's a pattern that
would fit this is also called a
stratified random arrangement and
another illustration is supposing you
picked up a series of relatively newborn
pups you have weaned them and then you
put them on different diets if you just
take a group at random from the whole
collection of animals you might get
those sort of results if however you
knew the parentage of the ones you have
picked up and were able to indicate
those in each of the outputs you might
find that in the red little one all
all of the diet the results were below
the day in the clear circles coming from
letter to you would get again all of the
diet be ones below diet a and similarly
for those from litter free and that
means you get a fairly good idea from
that that there is an effect of be
against a whereas you didn't when you
were not aware of the parentage they
came from factorial experiments are
essentially trying to get more
information from the same experimental
units and they do it economically and
they show how general findings are they
spread it across several of the factors
effectively you're doing more than one
experiment within the same time period
and if you want to think of it you can
think of a single fact to experiment as
a two-group comparison between
treatments a and B and if you wanted to
repeat that in two strains that's the
sort of patent you have you'd need twice
the number of animals if you do a
factorial design you then find that you
have both the strains within each of the
treatment groups so for each treatment
you have eight experimental units for
each strain you have eight experimental
units per tube only 16 altogether and in
these sort of experiments because you're
estimating the biological variability
from the whole of the experiment the
individual experimental groups in this
case say strain one treatment a can be
quite small here where you have only
four in each strain treatment
combination there's eight for each
treatment and eight for each strain and
16 for estimating variability although
because of other constraints you don't
get all the 16 15 degrees of freedom
so the key thing about these type of
designs is they show interaction between
the two or more factors and therefore
they are the good way of optimizing your
output it's particularly true when
you're looking for combination say of
age and drug dose in a series of
experiments where you're looking at the
drugs mechanism action they show you
what is the optimal combination so to
summarize I think the top denies a
researcher needs clear objectives and
testable hypotheses a good understanding
of how to obtain valid reliable results
adequate and appropriate controls
correct identification and experimental
unit and under voyance of bias but they
also need the skill to select an
appropriate and efficient design an
understanding of how to minimize
severity and the way to bring this
across in teaching is not just by
presentations digress but by also
including some elements of problem
solving identifying the experimental
units as we did in the course of this
but also looking at what control you'll
need in certain scenarios looking at
designs which are 40 and seeing if
people can pick those out and also
allowing them to select from a series of
possible designs for ones which are
appropriate for a particular scenario
and you use a facilitated discussion to
bring that out and also to think about
the impact on the animals and how you
might minimize it and by questioning
people you get them to think about what
they would do and to make a decision and
that reinforces the key points although
it has to be done without causing them
embarrassment or distress themselves and
that's where we'll end for that and give
a chance to come back on any of the
points thank you
dr. fry for that precipitation so a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window dr. fryer will
answer as many questions as time permits
will give you sometimes formulate
questions
is it possible to show the results of
the poll on experimental unit at all yes
I believe I believe retention that's
interesting isn't it only about half of
people have picked out the female and it
that's about what you might expect from
looking at papers quite often people
have not picked out the correct
experimental unit and you can see it
from the published paper well if there
are no questions today I would once
again like to thank dr. Derek fry for
his presentation do you have any final
comments dr. fry no I think we've
covered rather a lot what I haven't done
is talked about different teaching
methods but those are so applicable to
the local circumstances but it's quite
difficult to generalize well was
wonderful I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today um this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free race continuing education credits
after the webinar is over and to get
your CD credits click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page this web casting to you
on demand through August fourth 26
chains lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay and
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues you may have missed
today's life event until next time
goodbye thanks very much to lab roots oh
you know what we have a question here we
have several questions would you have
you have time to answer some questions
well we go four or five minutes and I've
got a bit longer okay so let's see this
one and decide besides a statistician
what other subject matter experts would
you suggest consulting um usually with
regard to severity and sometimes with
regard to what can be done without
animals the local vets can help and most
places
have some that that will come along to
deal with the laboratory animals and
they are getting better at thinking
about design as to think from just what
the severity is okay well thank you for
asking different experimenters and there
are a fair number of sites now go three
are for example give some idea of
severity as well as other adverse
effects great okay well I um I see that
a number of people have written in to
ask about copies of the presentation so
I just like everyone to know for a copy
of the presentation um it will be
available for downloading later during
the on-demand period so yes i-i've
hadn't been able to do a summary set of
these yet but will do by about this time
tomorrow okay great and as we said the
webcast the on-demand period extends
through august 4 2016 so again thank you
dr. Frey thank you Tom to finding us